hello my name is JD Quinn I'm going to
be the host for today for 3abn today
Bible Q&A I know personally this is one
of my favorite programs I think we
always have questions and hopefully
sometimes those questions are answered
and boy when it comes to the biblical
questions they're very important to us I
want to introduce our two people today
normally we have four but we've got two
today and coming directly from
California Pastor James rafy glad that
you're here James good to be here JD and
Shelly it's always a privilege to be
part of the Q&A and to get into the word
of God and answer viewers questions amen
I know that we always love hearing what
you have to say and then to my right is
my precious wife a Bible student in her
own right and that's Shelley Quinn
Shelley welcome it's so good to see you
today it's good to see you again
uh we just want to thank all of those of
you from home who have texted or emailed
in your questions and we're going to do
our best to stick to the Bible alone to
answer Solo scriptura solo scriptura now
I think that uh what makes to me what
makes this program special is that the
questions are coming from you so how do
you get the questions to us we have
three Avenues of getting those questions
to us so that we can then turn around
hopefully find the answers that are in
the Bible and then share them with you
if you're going to text you would say
618 228
3975 look at the bottom of your monitor
there and I think that uh you'll be able
to see that I'll say it again 618 228
3975 if you would rather email email
would be at Bible qa3 3ab
bn. once again Bible
QA
3abn.org
questions fathers we come to you today
in the name of Jesus thank you Lord
thank you for being in our hearts being
in our minds father we're hungry for you
and father as we have this opportunity
to be able to find questions that people
are interested in and find answers we
just ask Lord through the aid of the
holy spirit that on both sides you will
be blessed Lord we love you we thank you
in the name of Jesus amen amen amen amen
we're going to start with Shelly
shelle's going to take the first
questions then we're just going to
alternate these are good questions first
one
Shelly can you help me understand that
the Trinity has three different entities
I've heard that God is the spirit along
with Jesus I just want to know what the
truth is and this is from Sue in New
Mexico Sue this is such an important
question and so important to understand
the answer I'm going to give I recently
answered this on another program I'm
going to take that same an answer but
expand it just a little in the Bible we
find
58 triadic passages that means there's
58 times that the Lord explains himself
as being three different persons who are
One Sovereign God the god the New
Testament uses the word
godhead and let me give you a couple of
examples in Matthew
28:19 Jesus says go therefore and Make
Disciples of all the nations baptizing
them in the name of the Father the Son
and the Holy Spirit so Jesus is
instructing his disciples to to baptize
in the name of all three 2 Corinthians
13:14 one of my favorites Paul says that
he wants the grace of our Lord and
Savior Jesus Christ the love of the
father or the love of God and The
Fellowship of the Holy Spirit to be with
you all so once again we see God
presented as three persons who are one
God the godhead is God the Father Son
and Holy Spirit so how how do we how
does that make sense it is not 1 + one +
one it is 1 * 1 * 1 which equals 1
that's 1 to the 3 power and it's
interesting that's that's another way of
saying one to the3 power is a cube
something that is the same dimensions in
their height the width and the length
and so we find God's presence in the
cube we see that the holy of holies was
exactly identical in its Dimensions it
was a cube the New Jerusalem is as well
in Genesis 2:24 God shows us that he
uses this multiplication formula to
describe one when he says therefore a
man shall leave his father and mother
and be joined to his wife they shall
become one flesh so 1 Time 1 equals one
there all three persons of the godhead
are very actively involved in the Plan
of Salvation and the Holy Spirit is the
third person of the godhead let's see
how Jesus introduced his coming in John
16-18 Jesus said John 141
16-18 I will pray the father and he will
give you another helper that he may
abide with you let's pause another in
the Greek another there's two words for
another in the Greek Heros which means
another that is similar to so like if we
were saying another piece of fruit that
an orange would be another piece of
fruit in come comparison to an Apple
that's heteros but the other Greek word
is alos a l l oos and it means one
exactly the like it's a perfect
duplication so Jesus says I'm going to
send another alos helper helper is the
pericos in the Greek and that is a
person a person who is an advocate a
person who would continue Christ's
Ministry on Earth so he says I'm going
to pray the father he's going to send
you another helper a person who's just
like me that he may abide with you
forever the spirit of Truth whom the
world cannot receive because it neither
sees him nor knows him but you will know
him for he will dwell within you so the
Holy Spirit possesses exactly the same
qualities and characteristics of Christ
and the father because the holy spirit
is a person of the godhead he's a
conscious intelligent person now let me
get to this very
quickly the longest recorded prayer of
Jesus was in John 17 where he is praying
to the father for himself for his
disciples and for all people and his
intercession for us to the father proves
he's a distinct person from the father
like likewise the Holy Spirit intercedes
on our behalf and his intercession
proves that he is a distinct person
Romans 8:26 the Holy Spirit also helps
in our weaknesses we don't know what we
should pray for as we want but the
spirit himself makes intercession for us
so that proves he is a separate and
distinct person good answer Shelly amen
amen James Pastor rafy was God's initial
plan when he created Adam to one day
come and save him or did that plan
become or did that plan come because
Adam sinned and this is from Briston and
mauwi good question Briston in Malo
great question in fact the quick answer
is the plan came into being or effect
because Adam and Eve sinned it was not
God's desire that we sin and needed to
be rescued from sin so the Plan of
Redemption was laid before the
foundation of the world however it
wasn't put into operation until after
Adam and Eve sinned so we see in the
Bible that Jesus was the lamb slain from
the foundation of the world there are a
couple of texts that we can look at to
understand this the first one is one of
Shelley Quinn's favorite texts if not
her very favorite text Revelation 13 and
verse 8 here's what it says there and
all that dwell upon the Earth shall
worship him that is the Beast power
whose names are not written in the Book
of Life of the lamb slain from the
foundation of the world so this Plan of
Salvation was put in place before the
world was created Jesus was predestined
to be our savior if Adam and Eve should
sin and the plan came into being because
Adam and Eve sinned and we see this more
clearly even more clearly in First Peter
uh first Peter uh is going to starting
with Verse 18 is going to tell us in a
fuller sense how this plan went deene it
says in verse 18 for as much as you know
that you were not redeemed with
corruptible things as with silver and
gold from your vain uh conversation
received by by tradition from your
fathers but verse 19 with the precious
blood of Christ as of a lamb without
blemish and without spot who verily was
foreordained before the foundation of
the world but was manifest in these last
times for you so for ordained is uh it's
a complicated word but it simply means
to decide ahead of time predestined to
for orain to decide ahead of time so it
was decided ahead ahead of time that if
we should sin if we should fall if we
should receive or be deceived by Satan
and receive his lies against God and
fall out of God's grace that we would
have a backup plan that backup plan
would be Jesus Christ the Lamb of God
slain from the foundation of the world
now it wasn't God's purpose that we sin
God didn't determine that this world was
going to be The Dumping Ground uh for
Satan and for sin yeah the way I could
illustrate this is kind of like a spare
tire in an automobile you know you you
have this this tire in your car and I
always like to have a spare tire just in
case right just in case you get a flat
tire the plan of of Salvation didn't
require that God's perfect creation get
a flat tire that God's perfect creation
fall into sin The Plan of Salvation
didn't require that God did not ordain
sin uh sin was not a necessity God did
not create a planet for the purpose of
sin it wasn't a grand experiment for sin
but God forsaw sin you know God saw the
possibility of sin uh he is allseen he's
all knowing sin didn't catch him by
surprise uh God was not unaware of this
possibility and God made a provis vision
for it so the fall of Adam and Eve did
not catch God by surprise so hopefully
that answers the question uh the
question basically a asking you know was
it in God's initial plan sin in God's
initial plan the plan of of Salvation
God's initial plan or did it come about
um after Adam sinned or because Adam
sinned and that answer of course is it
came about after Adam sinned but it was
something that was put in place from the
creation of the foundation of the world
amen amen answer good answer Shelly your
second question what Bible translation
does the Adventist Church recommend I
enjoy the NLT which is the New Living
Translation but found out that there are
some missing verses so I have changed
over to the new King James
version okay let me uh just start by
saying in 2 Timothy 3 and verse 16 Paul
tells us all scripture is given by
inspiration of God it's profitable for
Doctrine for Repro for correction for
instruction and righteousness no
Doctrine no teaching from the Bible is
built on a single scripture I want to
say that up front the Bible was written
the Old Testament Hebrew with some short
passages ver make the New Testament in
Greek they don't translate word for word
into English and some other uh you know
they're complicated so so Bible
translators have to do their best to try
to stay uh faithful to the passage what
it's it's saying but once again
doctrinal understanding is not based on
a single scripture and God has
absolutely
provided in and protected the Integrity
of his word it's not a matter of a
particular wording you know if you look
at an amplified Bible anything that's in
parentheses is all the words that the
Greek could mean that kind of amplifies
our understanding the Seventh Day
Adventist Church does not officially any
endorse any particular Bible translation
but let me give you this understanding
there's three basic types of
translations there's the
essentially literal that means it is
doing its best to be word for word the
order of the words is not always the
same because they don't translate the
same but then there is a dynamic
equivalent which means the dynamic
equivalent is a thought forth thought
translation and then there's the free
paraphrase this is uh using contemporary
phrases and metaphors to convey what a
person thinks that they're trying to say
it's more um going by the interpretation
of the author for in-depth study and
public reading for doctrinal
determination the word forword
translations like King James Version New
King James Version the
nasb the English Standard or the revised
standard those are the best to use if
you are trying to get a true
understanding of Doctrine for indepth
study and public reading that's what I
would use now for an easier
understanding the dynamic translation
that's what you're reading a New Living
Testament is a dynamic it's a thought
for Thought um of the dynamic I think
the NIV is the best because it's the
closest to the literal meaning in most
cases but there's the NIV the NLT uh the
contemporary English version remember
that's thought for thought and a lot of
times those thoughts are helping you to
interpret where I think God wants us to
get in and let the Holy Spirit help us
interpret um for devotional reading the
free the um free paraphrase like the
clear word the living Bible the message
these are not something that you want to
use for
doctrinal development because they are
meant to be like a devotional reading
it's not something that some they make
some departures especially the message
makes pretty clear departures
from um the original but I'll tell you
what I know people I know a pastor that
was burned out he picked up the message
and read it and guess what it brought
him back into study it rejuvenated him
so I'm not saying anything bad I do want
to say this some people believe that
King James version is the only standard
we cannot use any Bible translation as a
standard for other translations it's the
manuscripts that matter King James
version was written from manuscripts
discovered in the 11th century for
example new King James versions many
more manuscripts have been discovered
and they go back as early as the 4th
Century that's new King James comes from
that so um I think that what we have to
know is if you enjoy King James version
ah read it and enjoy it but don't let's
be gracious and respect what
translations other people like I
personally use uh multiple translations
and I will read different bibles if you
have a a a smartphone let me give you a
tip you can say the name of a verse like
2 Corinthians 5:17 add Bible Gateway and
it will take you to the Bible Gateway
website a free Bible app that will give
you five or six different versions so
that you can compare and come to a
better understanding very well put great
answer
James will there be a physical temple in
eternity on the the new earth based on
what Revelation talks about God in the
lamb being the temple in other words was
the temple only place after sin and will
it exist forever and this is from Shawn
in
Michigan sha in Michigan that is an
excellent question you're basing that
question of course in Revelation chapter
21 and verse 22 and it says I saw no
Temple therein for the Lord God Almighty
and the lamb are the Temple of it and
really this verse is the conclusion of
the whole picture of the Plan of
Salvation The Book of Revelation of
course is uh summarized in the entire
Bible all the books of the Bible meet
and end in Revelation and then
revelation 21- 22 kind of close out the
whole Plan of Salvation so this verse
has a little bit more weight in my
understanding of this subject of the
temple but as you go back to the Book of
Revelation uh chapter 7 for example you
definitely find a temple in Revelation 7
this is probably a picture of the
redeemed in heaven before the end of the
Thousand Years but as you get down
toward the end of the text they're
definitely on the new Heaven and the new
Earth because you see them uh promis
that they will never hunger anymore or
thirst anymore and that the lamb will
lead them beside The Fountains of waters
and wipe away all tears from their eyes
now I don't think that they're literally
on the new Earth at the end of this
verse necessarily and this picture shows
them worshiping God in his Temple verse
15 day and night so definitely there's a
temple in heaven when we go to heaven
with Christ at the second coming when we
go to heaven with him for that Thousand
Years there's definitely a temple there
we know that and then we see Revelation
11 verse1 it indicates that there's a
Temple because it's to be measured
measure the temple and of God and the
Altar and then the worship worship
therein verse 19 indicates there's a
Temple because it says the temple of God
was opened in heaven again all of these
texts seem to indicate a time frame that
is pre- new Heaven and new earth and
then in Revelation chapter 15 we have
the Temple of god mentioned and the
testimony opened and we have Angels
coming out of the temple and we have the
seven last plagues being poured out but
Jesus kind of affirms what John is shown
in Revelation 21 in John
2:19 Jesus said unto them destroy this
Temple pointing to himself and in 3 days
I will raise it up again and of course
Psalm
7713 tells us thy way oh God is in the
sanctuary who is so great a God as our
God Jesus affirms that in John 14:6 and
says I am the truth the way and the life
so the entire Temple service pointed to
God and the Plan of Salvation once
salvation is complete the service of
Applied sacrifice through intercession
and mediation forgiveness is no longer
necessary final atonement is going to be
finished there's no longer a need for a
veil to hide God's glory the atonement
day of atonement is finished the
scapegoat all of that is done the only
Eternal need for a sanctuary is worship
and since we are to see God face to face
we will worship him directly and not
through types and veils and Creation in
this way God himself is the temple as
noted by The Words of Christ to say that
there is no Temple there in is in my
present understanding to say that there
is no need for mediation for
ministration of sacrifice that was
typified by this Earthly Temple and
pointed of course to the Heavenly Temple
literal temple in heaven and the Plan of
Salvation the temple Services were to
reconcile us to God and once that is
accomplished the reality of the temple
is God himself we are to serve God
himself so the reality of that literal
Sanctuary service that was typified in
the Earthly and pointed toward the
Heavenly has been served then in that
time when this New Jerusalem comes down
to this earth God and the lamb are the
temple that we serve day and
night amen man that's good stuff there
thank you much Pastor
Shelly your third
question Psalm
685 reads a father to the fatherless is
God the mother to those without mothers
in this world and this is from Devon in
Virginia Devon I love this question and
I love the heart behind it in Genesis
1:27 the Bible says that God created man
in his own image in the image of God he
he
created him male and female he created
them so both genders are created in
God's image those qualities and
attributes that we think of as being
fatherly or paternal come from God those
attributes we think of as being motherly
maternal come from God and so the Bible
doesn't exclude
God is always referred to as father but
it doesn't
exclusively use male gender metaphors
masculine metaphors let me give you some
that this this will help broaden your
understanding of God God is speaking in
Isaiah
42:14 he says I have kept my PE held my
peace a long time I have been still and
restrained myself now I will cry like a
woman in labor
I will pant and gasp at once he goes on
in Isaiah
4915 and 16 he says can a woman forget
her nursing child and not have
compassion on the son of her womb surely
they may forget yet I will not forget
you see I have inscribed you on the
palms of my hands your walls are
continously before me in Isaiah
6613 he said as one whom his mother
Comforts so I will comfort you and you
shall be comforted in Jerusalem God is
comparing himself here to that M what we
think of maternal the motherly instincts
Jesus said in Matthew
22:37 oh Jerusalem Jerusalem the one who
kills the prophets Stones those who are
to her how often I wanted to gather your
children together as a hen gathers her
chicks under her wings but you were not
willing you
know the commed common image in the Old
Testament we see God as the mother bird
who is protecting and
Sheltering her children under her wings
for warmth for comfort and protection
from danger quick examples Psalm
178 keep me as the apple of your eye
hide me under the shadow of your wings
Psalm 57 1-2 be merciful to me oh God be
merciful to me for my soul trusts in you
and in the shadow of your wings I will
make my refuge until these calamities
have passed out I will cry out to God
most high to God who performs all things
for me and then I love this one in
Deuteronomy 32 in verse 11 God says as
an eagle stirs up the nest hovers over
its young spreading out its wings and
taking them out carrying them on its
wings he's comparing God to the eagle
now I don't know if you've ever seen
this we saw it in our backyard one day a
mother I think it was a hawk rather than
an eagle but the babies were on the edge
of the of the nest looking out and she
knocked them out and guess what when she
knocked them out they went tumbling down
and sh she went and she brought it up so
God teaches us and he even compares his
maternal instincts to a bear listen to
this he says I will meet them this is
Hosea 13 at I will meet them like a bear
that is robbed of her Cubs and I will
Ren the covering of their heart there I
will devour them like a lioness as a
wild beast would tear them so both
maternal and paternal motherly and
fatherly attributes are God so in answer
to your question Devon yes God is also a
mother to the motherless amen amen James
third question I'm confused used about
the 144,000 virgins I was wondering if
that was the pure Church of Jesus Christ
instead of literal people could the
144,000 virgins be the pure Church of
Christ who kept his Commandments and did
not defile themselves with women like
the apostasy church and that's from
scant in
Pennsylvania that is a great question
scun in
Pennsylvania let's just look at
Revelation because in Revelation 4 14
there are eight basic characteristics of
the 144,000 and it's going to be helpful
to look at each one of them and identify
them biblically because remember as I
mentioned in our last question the Book
of Revelation is kind of a summary of
the entire Bible it's not an isolated
book at the end of the Bible That's all
to itself it really is taking the
message of the Bible and Distilling it
down in symbolic language to kind of
summarize the whole Plan of Salvation so
when we look at the Book of Revelation
we're inclined at times to apply it
simply to a final generation of people a
few people at the end of time are remant
people at the end of time but God
doesn't have that in mind in the Book of
Revelation God is revealing prophecy
that begins in John's day and takes us
to the new Heaven and the new Earth and
is all inclusive of the redeemed so do
the characteristics of the 144,000 in
Revelation CH 14 do they allow room for
the inclusion of more more than just a
final generation of people more than
just the pure people quote unquote that
you had mentioned there and we want to
look at these characteristics and give
them biblical uh support so the first
one it says in Revelation 14 that they
stand on Mount Zion now this is to be
the place that is to be occupied by all
of the redeemed if you read Hebrews 12:
22- 23 and I'm just going to give you
the references for time sake you're
going to find that every single person
who's redeemed is named as part of the
Church of God on Mount Zion so this
would apply to all of the redeemed then
it says that they have their father's
name written in their foreheads this is
the second characteristic of the 144,000
this also would include every single one
of the redeemed because in Revelation
22:4 we're told that we're going to see
his face and his name is going to be in
our foreheads that includes all of the
red redeemed then we're told that the
redeem they are redeemed from among men
that would include every single person
who's redeemed because all of us are
redeemed from among men we didn't come
from another planet even though Men Are
from Mars and women are from Venus we're
all from planet Earth Fallen planet
Earth We're All redeemed from among men
there are two verses you can look at
concerning that Isaiah
43:1 and 1 Peter 1 verse 18 then we're
told that they are virgins now this is
point number four they are virgins now
the apost AP identifies all who believe
the gospel and who follow Jesus to be
chased virgins and that's 2 Corinthians
chap 11 veres 2-4 Christ actually uses
the same symbolic terminology to
describe those who profess faith in him
in Matthew 25 and verse one the next
characteristic characteristic number
five they follow the lamb now this also
applies to all faithful Believers not
just literal Jews according to 1
Thessalonians 1:6 and John 12:26 Old
Testament Believers look forward to the
lamb New Testament Believers look back
to the lamb but the cross Calvary and
the lamb slain from the foundation of
the world is Central to the experience
of the Old Testament Believers and the
New Testament Believers we all must
follow the lamb some symbolically some
literally in the sense that Christ
fulfilled those symbols and then number
six they are first fruits what does that
mean according to the Bible this means
they are begotten or born again and you
can look at James 1 17 to18 and of
course John 3:3 so according to Jesus
this experience is a qualifier for all
who enter Heaven Old Testament New
Testament faithful everyone has to be
born again to enter Heaven that would
apply to all number seven they have no
guile in their mouths this also is the
experience of all who genuinely accept
Christ as their righteousness whether
they're Jews or Gentiles 1 Peter 3:10
Psalm 32:2 We Stand without God through
the righteousness of Jesus Christ and
then number eight they stand without
fault before God so the promise of the
word of God is that Jesus is able to
present us without fall before his
throne this too is the privilege of
everyone including the thief on the
cross who trusted in Christ at the last
minute he too is presented without fault
Before the Throne of God and you can
look up Jude verse 24 to authenticate
that truth so the 144,000 is ail
symbolic number 144 is 12 * 12 Old
Testament tribes are 12 New Testament
Apostles are 12 a th000 is the largest
number in the Bible this number is
symbolic representing the redeemed of
the Old Testament the redeemed of the
New Testament the largest number so
large that no man can number them
according to Revelation 7 and verse 9
that's the best answer I've ever heard
to that question thank you thank you
thank you James let me just take a few
uh seconds here and remind you how you
can contact us if you want to text us
that's
618 228
3975 if you want to email us that's
Bible QA 3abn.org
can Christian women wear
makeup the only reason I took this
question is because it comes in
frequently and so I will do my best to
answer answer this from the Bible only
the Bible in the Old Testament there are
four verses that could be applied to
makeup in the new too let's look at that
cuz we want to say no more no less than
what the Bible says um
in Jeremiah
4:30 uh it says though you you clothe
yourself with Crimson you though you
Adorn yourself with ornaments of gold
though you enlarge your eyes with paint
in vain you will make your self Fair
your lovers will despise you they will
seek your life doesn't sound like a
reputable woman there um Second Kings
9:30 is speaking of Jezebel and she
paints she puts paint on her eyes and it
said you she put paint on her eyes she
adorned her hair and she looked through
the window Ezekiel
23:40 says furthermore you sent men to
come from afar to whom a messenger was
sent there they came you washed yourself
for them you painted your eyes and
adorned yourself with ornaments so all
three of those don't sound like it's
very favorable but then Esther 212
speaks of Esther having to undergo 12
months of beauty treatments oil myr and
cosme perfume and cosmetics before she
went
to before the king now I don't see any
one of those four
prohibiting makeup but let's go further
let's look at the New Testament 1
Timothy 2:9 and10 Paul writes in like
manner also that the women Adorn
themselves in modest apparel with
propriety and moderation notice that not
with braided hair or gold or pearls or
costly clothing but which is proper for
women professing godliness with good
works so his emphasis is on personal
Purity his emphasis is on good works his
emphasis is on internal versus external
but does he say say that makeup is wrong
anything that we do it's a matter of the
heart anything that we do to draw
attention to ourself in a manner that
Puffs us up with pride is
sin that that's just the bottom line if
we're chasing
after vanity and selfish adoration it's
misplaced priorities if we are are we
trying to look like a seductress are we
trying to um draw men's attention to us
what is our
purpose you know Paul's actually
speaking here about
spending money on expensive clothing it
would be better spent
on helping the poor and men have a
problem with that just as much as women
there's some people who spend way too
much money on their wardrobe ex and make
extravagant wardrobe robes so Paul's
addressing the issue in the church that
was causing distraction the women Drew
attention to themselves they braid up
their hair in these elaborate hair dos
with gold and silver and they wore their
jewels and his conclusion is what are
you doing God doesn't look at the
external he looks at the heart and his
emphasis is on matters of the heart now
Peter is the only second that this is
the second scripture in the New
Testament 1 Peter
33-5 do not let your adornment be merely
outward arranging the hair wearing gold
putting on fine apparel rather let it be
the hidden person of the heart with The
Incorruptible beauty of a gentle and
quiet Spirit which is very precious in
the sight of the Lord once again Peter
is putting emphasis on inward adornment
on what uh it's more important than
outward
adornment when Christian women Adorn
themselves do I think it's wrong the
Bible has little to say about makeup I
don't see that it is prohibited but it
must be done in a manner that doesn't
violate Christian principles in other
words it's a matter of the heart what is
the purpose are you trying to be
seductive are you pridefully flaunting
your beauty are you trying to draw
attention to self in a vain glorious
prideful way all of those things are
wrong God is much more interested in our
heart and we should not be Vain and
puffed up about anything because that
does not follow Christ's example thank
you sh thank
you Pastor could you please explain
Isaiah
6520 is Isaiah talking about what it
what will take place in the future and
this is Norma in
Florida great question Norma in Florida
thank you for that Isaiah 65:20 says no
more shall an infant from there live but
a few days nor an old man who has not
fulfilled his days for the child shall
die a hundred years old but the sinner
being 100 years old shall be accursed
and that's Isaiah 65:20 you know this
text has perplexed Bible students for
generations and the awkward wording
seems to imply that even death might
still play a part with the Saints in
God's New World of Tomorrow some have
taken the context to indicate a
subjunctive that is a hypothetical
situation or form of speech in the
translation and I like that this would
indicate that the prophet was using a
human terminology to describe Heavenly
conditions in other words Isaiah was
saying should or if certain conditions
Prevail then such and such would be the
result so the translation I think this
idea seems to give the closest uh
understanding to the original meaning if
we put in the subjective sense here's
what it would sound like there shall no
more a child there shall be no child to
arise or come into being who shall live
only a certain number of days if it were
possible that there is still sinners in
Jerusalem there won't be and if one of
them should be punished with death when
100 years old he would be regarded as a
cur of God and forever cut off from
Mercy if one should die a natural death
of 100 which he won't he would still be
a boy so Isaiah was seeking to
illustrate the facts of eternal life in
Heaven by Earthly
comparisons and therefore he had to call
upon his readers to imagine certain
mortal conditions as being in the new
Earth so they could grasp the truth of
immorality or immortality and that's the
best answer that I've ever read that was
uh that answer was given by Joe Cruz in
his book answers to difficult Bible
texts and just to illustrate this again
subjective tense is like saying on
Monday morning I wish it were Friday I'd
be going home early I'd be spending the
weekend with my family I'd be relaxing I
wouldn't be at work but it's not Friday
it's Monday so the subjective s tense is
is something that is theoretical that is
something that is putting yourself in
your imagination putting yourself
somewhere that you're not and then
illust giving uh and using that as an
illustration and that's what we see
happening in this
text very good I thought it was very
good thank you James Shelly your fifth
question could you please explain First
Timothy 29 I'm an African woman and have
always braided my hair have I been
committing a sin and this is from Don in
New York Don I want to tell you I love
you sister what a precious heart you
have let me start reading something that
has nothing to do with what you're
saying yet it's exactly to do with what
you're saying John 6:27 Jesus said do
not labor for the food which perishes
but for the food which endures to
everlasting life which the son of man
will give you because God the father has
set his seal on him in context Jesus
isn't saying that we shouldn't work to
provide for our Liv living he's saying
don't allow that work to monopolize our
time we should be seeking the uh working
for the food that comes from heaven so
there's a literary technique that is
used in the Bible that warns us against
substituting something that is temporal
something that's a fleeting action for a
better Godly action does this make sense
so when this is what Paul is
doing he is saying okay 1 Timothy 2:9
let women Adorn themselves modestly with
propriety and and moderation and I
talked about it on the last one not with
hair that's all braided up and knotted
up and elaborate things to draw
attention to yourself he's focusing on
modesty moral Purity it's proper to
groom your hair I have naturally curly
hair I'm going to tell you what braids
can be modest braids are practical
they're less costly you're not sending
he's not saying don't braid your hair
any more than Jesus was saying don't go
out and work for a livelihood it's a
literary technique and you are not
sinning amen good for you
amen
James I've read acts
8:39 and have been wanting to know what
it means was Phillip completely gone how
did the Holy Spirit take him away from
the unic also wonder about Luke
24:36 when Jesus appeared suddenly in
the midst of his disciples how did Jesus
appear suddenly and this is from Joe in
Florida great question Joe in Florida
we're looking at the text here in Acts
chapter 8 verse 39 and when they were
come up out of the water the spirit of
the lord caught away Philip that the
unic saw him no more and he went on his
way rejoicing but Philip was found at
aotus and passing through he preached in
all the cities till he came to ciceria
so this word cod away in the Greek is
used about 17 times in the New Testament
about 12 of those times has a more
literal meaning and about four of those
times it's more of a symbolic meaning
let me give you an example of the
symbolic meaning Paul says in 2
Corinthians 12: 2 and 4 I knew a man in
Christ above 14 years whether in the
body I cannot tell or out of the body I
cannot tell God God knows such a one was
caught up to the third he third heaven
he's talking there about a vision that
he had he's talking about a spiritual
application to this then literally the
word is used in verses like John 6:15
when Jesus therefore perceived that they
would come and take him same word by
force to make him King he departed again
into a mountain himself alone so was
philli literally caught up by the Holy
Spirit and transported somewhere or was
he supernaturally caught up by the Holy
Spirit and transported somewhere I lean
toward the literal interpretation in
this text it doesn't dismiss the fact
the possibility that the Su there was a
supernatural transporting of Philip to
another place but I think what it's
basically saying is the the Holy Spirit
Led Philip to another place the unic
didn't see him again he went to minister
in another location and the reason I
lean in that direction is because we
don't really find a lot of Bible verses
that indicate that the holy Spirit Works
in this manner on a regular basis
transporting people supernaturally from
one location to the next doesn't dismiss
that that possibility but I think the
evidence the biblical evidence leans
toward the literal translation as far as
Jesus showing up among the disciples we
know that Christ entered the upper room
with the two disciples who would run
back to Jerusalem to tell the other
disciples they'd seen Jesus you know
they were on the road there Jesus met
them he explained who he was he broke
bread with them they recognized and
finally they ran back and Jesus entered
the room with them probably not seen by
them or the others because they were so
excited but the suddenness um could also
be explained by the fact that Christ was
glorified right so he wasn't restricted
by doors or walls uh he could show up
Suddenly anywhere in in the in the
glorified body that he now had he wasn't
restricted by the physicalness of his
Humanity after his resurrection so
either way we know that this was an
event uh where Christ either came in
among the disciples with the two or came
in uh in his glorified body to present
himself there and we shouldn't be
surprised by that they were terrified at
first because you know they weren't uh
ready for this glorified Christ but now
we today know Christ is in a glorified
body he can show up on Mount on Patmos
and talk to John uh he can show up
anywhere at any time uh in that body
because that body is is spiritual not
literal not physical in the sense that
we have
physicalness amen amen very good well we
still have a couple of minutes here do
you have any additional comments on
something that you said before I just
want to
ensure please understand that we are so
tough on each
other you know we can have such a
critical spirit I want you to remember
that God looks at our heart what is so
important is our spiritual development
of our character God wants us to turn to
him it there's nothing we can do to save
ourself he wants us to be totally
dependent upon him and quit what what
will keep you out of Heaven faster than
anything is a critical judgmental Spirit
or that sense of Pride that you're
you're doing something that's going to
get you saved turn to God just let him
love you let him lead you things will be
good amen amen amen and just to add to
this you know we've dealt with some
pretty challenging questions here I
thought my questions were challenging
till I heard J's questions and I
realized whoo we've got some challenging
questions here hopefully we've laid a
good biblical foundation for these
answers
and that's the most important thing we
here at 3n really believe that the Bible
is our priority and we want to direct
you to the scriptures now if you've seen
something in the Bible that would be a
little bit different or perhaps uh not
line up with some of the answers we've
given send that into us we're we're open
we are students of the scripture and we
want to be open to the leading of the
holy spirit in the word of God but if
you're just going to share your opinion
your thoughts we're going to take you
back direct you back to the word of God
because we believe the word of God is
our only safety the scriptures are our
safe God guard especially in these last
days amen thank you we're going to go to
an address row we'll be back in a couple
of minutes and then we'll just pick up
the last two minutes
okay if you're enjoying our 3abn Bible
Q&A then tell your friends each Monday
we'll bring you a fresh program
answering the Bible questions you s send
us using God's holy word to shed light
on those texts that seem difficult to
understand to have your questions
answered on a future program just email
them to us at bible QA
[Music]
3abn.org watch 3ab Bible Q&A for answers
from God's
word Shelly Pastor James you have any
additional comments or final thoughts I
just want
to reiterate what Jesus said in Luke
11:9 he said ask and keep on asking
seeking keep on seeking knock and keep
on knocking in verse 13 tells us what
we're asking seeking and knocking he
said if you being evil know how how to
give good gifts to your children how
much more will the heavenly father give
the Holy Spirit to those who ask and
keep on asking we can't walk the
Christian walk without him amen amen
just wanted to share a little bit on uh
the program salvation symbols and signs
we had a couple questions here on
Revelation 144,000 and the temple
whether it's going to be in the new
Heaven and new earth and we've done a
whole series on The Book of Revelation
and Daniel 72 30 minute presentations on
Revelation another 40 on Daniel and we
have study guides they are also
available online downloadable uh we have
most of on Revelation up and a few on
Daniel up so you can watch those
programs if you'd like to do some more
detailed study on these subjects you can
download the outlines they're great
outlines that go through the notes for
the program and they can help you to do
deeper research into the books of Daniel
Revelation that doesn't mean they'll
answer all your questions but hopefully
they will help to give you biblical
direction for a lot of the difficult
texts and passages that we have
especially in these prophetic books so
take advantage of that salvation symbols
and signs on your D dream Channel at 300
ABN amen wonderful Shelly James thank
you thank you thank you so much for
spending this time with us you could
have been doing anything that you wanted
to but you chose to spend it with us we
love you we thank you God bless you have
a wonderful
[Music]
day